I saw hungover I don't know how the lads
feel you know I know they took a couple
of punches but I think I'm probably
worse than them at this point HOF about
the whiskey on that live stream it was
hard I'm sort of start by saying wow
what a [__] event that the lads put
on Rick Ross disappearing it's it's a
brick Jo and that was just crazy and I
don't know how much further it's
possible to go at this point you know
congratulations - JJ commiserations to
login I mean they gave it all they put
it all on the line exactly how they said
they would they've completed it that's
it changed the [__] game for
youtubers forever this is the moment
where people will look back at YouTube
and go that's when they broke through
that when YouTube became mainstream it
was before Logan and ksi and theirs
after that's how important this is
that's what they've done for Christ's
sake it was like our Christmas
you got James Arthur on Twitter for some
reason just I don't know emote one of
the side men off next thing you know
like every single youtuber on planet
Earth was like that today [__]
not on my watch like this is our
Christmas there's just like no taking
this away from us we have arrived now
and it's because of these two large
sauce charismatic such showman such
athletes and willing to risk everything
in front of the world well done to them
both
and it was Jay Jay who pulled out the
win and honestly before the fight I
thought Logan is just too big like being
honest I didn't make it public but I
just thought Logan is gonna be too big
too quick and too much of an athlete
I'll [__] be honest I was really
worried for JJ I thought if Logan
catches him here could be really bad
when you meet them both in person it's
not you it's night in footman day I
don't mean that in it you know what I
mean though Logan so much [__] bigger
I was literally feeling like knots in my
stomach for JJ I never knew the guts
that this broke has because he has been
very fortunate in life he hasn't been
tested well now he's being tested and
he's proven if you're in a [__]
street fight you want someone like JJ
with you because the guy will swing for
the [__] fences like he will hold
nothing back and that I love them for it
you know what I mean sad for Logan it's
a really unfortunate way to lose a fight
by planes to top it you know don't beat
yourself up because you did well it's
not like you are beaten like in terms of
it was a battering or anything like that
it was a really unfortunate way to lose
that's a mistake that a bloke with no
prophytes will make either of them could
have made that mistake they're both
going and they're doing the best in the
heat of the moment millions of people
watching around the world they tried to
perform under pressure
you just got to do your best and you
know in my head I didn't feel like
either of them proved that they were
better than the other one and I was
quite happy about that because I didn't
want either of them to lose in a bad way
under the rules of boxing JJ was the
rifle winner
given his physical disadvantages and
even just having the balls to get in
their fair [__] place you kind of
take that away from him like honestly
fair play and fair play to both of them
for having the class afterwards they
shake hands it was a hell of a moment it
was the perfect moment in my opinion to
end this watching it on my live stream
was so [__] weird I mean 129 thousand
people I think we're watching us at one
point we had had a half a bottle of
whiskey in me and it was 5 a.m. so it
was like dreamlike you know like is this
really happening I've been waiting for
this what feels like a yay a year and a
half since the last one it's finally
here and a lots happened in that time
I've gotten to know Logan particularly
well and so I am sort of like am i
coming across the right way I remember
one point on the livestream changing
hands approach I'll go go on JJ and then
that was like did I just come out my
mouth Stan job GG come on so I'm
constantly watching a fight worrying
what people are gonna be perceiving me
else cuz I don't want to come across the
wrong way but as per usual I'm biased in
the first fight I was called biased
towards Joella in the second fight I was
called bias towards ksi in the third
fight I'm biased towards Logan I'm a
human it is really hard to be completely
neutral in every single way and
apparently I was biased towards Logan I
definitely didn't mean to be and I
thought I called a fairly down the line
and maybe my opinion of the fight was
confused with the opinion of the result
before this fight happened I got loads
of footage by accident of JJ sparring on
the run up to this fight you know what I
did with it
nothing why because I [__] all this
guy I would never betray his trust I
care about him even though I get on well
with Logan I never mentioned it wouldn't
even dream of doing that if I'm really
this couldn't that people seem to think
I am well then there you go
chignon I mean wouldn't have helped
Logan if I was in some sort of [__] in
Logan lawhead like
if I'm team Logan wouldn't I have gone
you know Logan you're fighting this guy
well I just happen to have like an hour
and a half of boxing of him do you want
to study this like team Mayweather
you might want to secure your Dropbox
just a little bit of advice yes you know
me and you think I'm some sort of
two-faced person like you don't you
don't cuz if anything ever happened to
Jay Jay and I was there I'd be [__]
straight in no questions asked and
anyone who knows me [__] knows that
from an emotional point of view this was
the ideal outcome for me I mean they get
a lot of [__] money
neither of them gets hurt all right one
of them one but neither of them look
worse than the other in my opinion so
they both all the heads high and go and
enjoy [__] life now from a boxing
point of view I think both of them will
probably watch it and then I could have
done bad you know all the pressure gets
on here
you probably don't perform at your best
I think I've seen them both perform
better in some of the training videos
that we've seen as a spectacle it wasn't
what they promised everyone it wasn't
what they'd want do have had you know I
really got a feel for just how far they
can go you know they're learning in
their 20s mid twenties how to box you
know a lot of pros fight from eight
years old you see in the level drop from
the main card when it got to the main
event it was a huge difference you know
after hearing some of the rumblings in
the build-up to this of them fighting
actual professional boxers doing more of
these as their friend and as a boxing
fan I actually think there should be the
very last fight that we see youtubers do
probably won't be because there's
probably a lot of [__] money in it
and if anyone should be wanting this to
carry on financially from a business
that might it's me I've done brilliant
with this phungster jaw and JJ and Logan
getting all these interviews getting all
this structure and we channeled it's
been [__] great for me and that's
still I'm suggesting that this should be
the end as great as JJ and Logan have
done from an entertainment standpoint
from a courage star might get in there
and lay it all on the line from a
sporting standpoint as hellacious as
athletes as these guys are they're never
gonna be to the level that you want to
be in professional boxing and in my
opinion while I think they're tough as
fork and they'd probably beat most
people on the street a [__] [__] they
should not be in the professional boxing
arena and this should be where it ends
this is a perfect fairy tale ending of
shakin hands we made a [__] ton of money
we changed the game because it was such
a special event it doesn't really matter
what happened in the ring as such
because it was a one-off but if this
becomes more regular you then are
relying not just on the show
eventually the product of the boxing
ring is actually going to be what is
selling the fights and you're gonna see
the value deteriorate massively the
specialness is going to go they're just
gonna be known as those youtubers who
try and box but aren't very good and
that isn't what I feel like they look
upon right now they look upon his
pioneers and I don't want them to ruin
that from a safety point of view they
have made millions the likes of which
professional boxers make after having
potentially very grueling fights
sometimes getting knocked out on the
weight of the title like risking their
lives against killers and they got to do
that against a youtuber who has trained
for a couple of years you got so lucky
and neither you hurt each other but
what's to say in the next fight someone
is really good and does not one of these
lads out and then their lives are
changed forever for the worst it's not
worth it they've got so many other
avenues to make money music movies like
even TV whatever this was another thing
that these guys have conquered they've
both conquered so much in their lives
what's the next thing go or the next
thing in my opinion because I think
they've become addicted to boxing
they're in love with boxing but they've
already chosen their Road as
entertainers and they're never gonna be
champions of boxing or anything like
that and I'm sure they're aware of it
but I just think this is the perfect way
to end it in that ring the way they did
it's been an absolute privilege for me
to be involved in this I love YouTube
and I love fighting so putting these two
together has been some of the most fun
moments of my entire life and watching
Joella JJ and Logan go from boys to men
in front of my eyes just purely through
the fight training that you they would
never have gone through this
transformation because of they luxury
lifestyle but they put themselves
through I'm so proud of them I'm so I'm
amazed actually I'm actually amazed
because I really didn't think any of the
three lads had the [__] guts that
they do they've blown me away and if
they want to carry on fighting then I'll
[__] support them but this is just my
honest opinion I reckon we should just
throw the [__] Mandal to Vidal Riley
the real YouTube boxer and
get behind him from now on if you want
more from pro boxers stay right here on
the church or the You Tube channels I've
got little known man called Tyson Fury
coming on the podcast get your questions
in for him to his on social media or and
also I'd need to say before I go a
massive thank you the six silk who
sponsored our livestream the other night
they're doing a sale fifteen percent off
on their website the links in the
description below when you use the code
true I check out get some nice get some
nice gear like this thank you very much
sick so I really appreciate it and once
again shout out are the boys you did it
all